طبعا العراق مستمر يعني على مدى عقود من
الزمن باسترجاع قطعها الاثريه
قبل ايام اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه عن استرجاع
قطعتين اثريتين من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كانت كانت طاقه هربتا خلال حرب
الخليج وهما عباره عن تمثالين احدهما من
عباره عن فيلم من الكلس والاخر عباره عن
ثور من المرمر وبحسب بيان وزاره الخارجيه
فانها بين القطعتين تبلغ قيمتهما
التقديريه 275 الف دولار امريكي هذه لم
تكن الخطوه الاولى باستعاده القطع الاثريه
فقط سبق وان عمل العراق على استعاده قطع
اخرى في 2021 تحديدا في يوليو 2021 استعاد
العراق حوالي سبعه عشره الف قطعه اثريه في
عمليه وسط بانها الاكبر طبعا ايضا من خلال
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وقيل ان هذه القطع قد كانت مهربه بين اربع
دول هي هولندا وايطاليا والولايات المتحده
واليابان ايضا وكذلك هذا العام ايضا
استرجع العراق حوالي 6000 قطعه اثريه من
بريطانيا وهذه القطع كانت قد استعارتها
بريطانيا لاغراض الدراسه عام
1923 طبعا منذ 2003 وبعد تهديم المتحف
المتحف الاثار متحف الوطني العراقي للاثار
واعاده افتتاحها في عام 2015 استلم المتحف
منذ عام 2015 والى الان حوالي سبع دفعات
عن طريق وزاره الخارجيه قطعه الاثريه
المهربه دفعات استلمها عام 2016 واخرها
هاتين القطعتين الاثاريتين قبل ايام شكرا
يا زينب على كل هذه المعلومات القيمه
للاسف انتهى وقتاش
الايامر والكاهي لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات